Hello and welcome to this next video. In this video we are going to be going back in and
setting up our new actor, the door, and we're going to be going through and looking how to
find and add modes to your graph and connect them up. Right, so I am back in the editor now.
Now I created a BP underscore door. Now if you didn't follow along at that point,
do feel free to right-hand click, select blueprint class, and we're going with the actor class,
and then we're just renaming it BP underscore door. Now I'm going to open up this
door that we have at the moment. I'm just going to delete all of the elements I used for
testing. That's including the cube and the rotating movement component, and this is where
we're actually going to be going ahead and we're going to be moving through creating our asset.
So the first thing I'm going to want to do is I am going to add some components to this
door, but I'm going to add some slightly different ones. So I'm going to come up to
the add button, left click, the first thing I'm going to search for is a static
mesh. Now this is actually the same as the cube and all the rest of them,
it just hasn't defined our static mesh yet. I'm going to call this door frame,
we'll call it sm underscore door frame. Now with that selected on the right hand side,
I bring out the viewport. We're not going to see anything yet. On the right hand side,
if I do in the drop down, I'm going to search for door. You should see that there is an sm
door. Once I select that, it should bring up a door frame that looks like this.
Okay, now I'm going to want to add in also a door. So I'm going to push plus again,
and I'm going to add another static mesh and search for the static mesh. And this time
I'm going to search for door again. At the top here, I have sm underscore door,
and that's going to bring in this door here. Now you may notice the door is slightly out of
sync. I'm going to move that to bring it in to be inside the door frame. Now one of the problems
that I've got is if you look here, I can't quite get it right. And that's because we have
snapping turned on. But what I'm going to do is I'm going to come up to the top section here.
Blue, I could turn off snapping by just unclicking it, but I still really want it to snap. I just
want it to be a smaller increment and then change it to five. And now when I move it,
it fits perfectly into our door frame. Now one of the things that you might notice about this
door frame is that its pivot is in the left corner. And this is great because this means
that just by changing the Z rotation, we are going to be able to open and close this dub.
Now I'm going to rename this static mesh, and we're going to call this SM underscore door.
Okay, so that looks good now. I want to add a couple of other things to this.
The first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to add in a point on it. When I add in the
point light, you can see that it's going to create it, and it's going to put it right to
the bottom. So I'm going to move this up, and I want to place it in front of the door.
I'm going to use this as a simple method of just updating the cover of the door.
We're going to use that to see if it is locked or unlocked. Okay, so here we have our
light. Now at the moment, you may have noticed in the components that some of these are indented,
and that's because they are childed to that component. So you can see here,
if I was to rotate this mesh, I'd also rotate the light. Now that's not ideal. So what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take the point light, and I am going to drag it so
that it'll be a child of the default route. And I'm going to go attach. Now we'll see if
we rotate the door, the light will stay in place. And that's better. That's how I wanted
in this instance. Okay, we need one final thing for this. And that is a collision box.
So I'm going to come into the thing, and I'm going to search for box collision. I don't want this to
be a child of the door. I want it to be attached to the same route again. I'm going to scale
this box up, move it up to the center. And then I'm going to scale it up so that it
encompasses the door. Now we're going to use this to detect if the player is close,
and if they would be able to open and close the door. So it's a rather straightforward way of just
detecting what overlaps from this box. Okay, so that is all of the components we need.
We have two meshes for the door, and we have a point light that we're going to use to change
the color of the door. And we have a collision box which we're going to use to detect if the
player is overlapping with it on. Okay, now if I compile and drag out, you can see that the
mesh that I've dragged into the world, in the world, I'm going to drag this down.
I'm going to put this directly in front of our player because we're going to want to test
this out a few times. So you now see that our door is directly in front of our player.
I'm actually going to rotate it because you can see that the light is on the other side.
This is an instance of the blueprint that we are creating here. And as we adapt this blueprint,
this is going to change correspondingly. Let's have a look at how we code because
we're here to actually do any coding. So before we write the code for this,
I want to go through how we do the coding itself. Now, you'll see that we've got a construction
script, and we have an event graph here. Now, on the event graph, you'll see that we have
three nodes. Even though they may be grayed out, that is event begin play,
event actor begin overlap, and event tick. Now, these are events which are already connected
to things within the engine. Begin play is connected to when the game or the application starts
or when this specific actor is spawned into the world. So for example, if I was to drag off
and type print string, you don't have to follow along with this. I'm just demonstrating
some stuff. You can see it says hello. Now, if I jump into the level, if I was to press
and press play, you'd see that it says hello in the top left hand corner.
And that's because whatever we have attached to this script here is going to run at the begin
play. Now, if I was to drag down, we have something called tick. Now, tick,
this will run on every single frame of the game by default. If I was to press play,
you can see in the left hand side here, we have a long, long list of halos. So that's
because with tick, this is running on every single frame. You may have heard people talk
about event tick and that you should avoid using it. I think that's a bigger discussion,
because lots of stuff uses event tick. And it's a very valid way of doing things.
A lot of the under the hood stuff always uses tick. Now, there's one more event that I
would like to show you, and that is construction script. Here we go. Now, construction script is
in a tab unto itself. That's because construction script runs at the point the
actor is placed in the level. Now, you can see here, I'll show you in the output log here.
In the log, as I move it around in the editor, it is triggering that event in the editor.
So that is at the point of construction. We will use this in order to set the lights.
But it's useful to understand that these are events, and they are events
which are already connected to something to do with the actor. And there are many more as well
that we can use or create. We're going to be using begin play as our kickoff point here.
There are two ways to create different nodes. The first one is going to be hotkeys.
And I'm going to show you three. There are a few, but it tends to be these three that
most people use frequently. And that is B. So if you hold down B and left click,
it's going to give us a branch. This is blueprints if statement.
And there's S. It's going to give us a sequence. All this will do is allow us to
format our code so it's slightly better. The first pin will be fired. And then after
whatever is connected to the Zen, then 0. Whatever is connected to the Zen 1 is going
to be fired off. And we can add more in just by bringing them down. And the final one that I
use frequently is D for delay. And this is just going to get the script to wait for a set period
of time denoted in seconds. And it's useful to make things delay to the next tick or a whole
load of different reasons. So those are the three. And again, that's B gives us a branch,
S gives us a sequence, and D gives us the delay. So those are the three most common hotkey
ones. The rest of them, what we're going to be doing is going to be right hand clicking.
And that's going to bring up this dropdown box with all of the different functions which
are available to us. Now, for example, if I was to search for print, we get the print string
and then select. It's going to bring this up. Now, this will also work if you drag off
something. If you were to drag a print string in, it will automatically connect it to the
pin that you've dragged off. In this case, the execution pin.
There's one element I'd like to show you, and that is in the top right hand corner,
we have a box that is ticked on by default, and that is context sensitive.
How in Unreal, there are thousands of functions, and most of them will only work in the right
place or if they're connected up correctly. And what's useful about this is it is going to limit
the search returned to what would work within this blueprint.
How you'll notice if I untick it that this gets a little smaller and we have a whole load
more functions available to us. There's also going to mean that when we get one of those functions,
it might not work in this blueprint. What's useful as well is if I was to drag in,
say for example, the component, if I drag off, this is going to return me an even smaller list.
And that's because this is going to only return me nodes which would have an input pin
of a point light. So for example, if I searched for color, I could set the light color,
but it would require an input pin of the component light component object reference.
So it's very, very useful that it's going to allow us to find nodes which are appropriate.
Now connecting up these pins, if you see here with the branch,
if I was to drag in, I'll be able to connect up this execution pin, which would mean this
would be the first thing that would run after we do begin play. Now I can break this by holding
down alt and left-clicking. That's going to break the pin and allow me to plug it in somewhere else.
Also, if I wanted to, if I hold it down control, I can drag and copy that down to
a different connection. Now one of the things that's interesting is if you left-hand click and
drag across, it's going to highlight all of these boxes. And with nodes, we can use the clipboard
in order to translate. So if I was to now press control X, it would delete them, control V would
paste them, paste them again, control C would copy them and I can paste them. Or I could even
use control D which would duplicate them like this and delete will delete everything that I
have appropriate. That's very useful. It's also useful that you can share that across
other projects and things and just copy and paste the nodes.
Let's have a quick look at our node itself. So if I was to bring in a more complicated function
such as align trace my channel and zoom in, what you can see here is on the left-hand side,
we have all of the input modes for our node. And on the right-hand side,
we have all of our output nodes. Now some of these you can manually enter,
some of them you need to plug elements in or you can do either. Down here, we have a drop-down
which will give us more options. And it's also worth seeing that on the right-hand side here,
we have this blue pin, which is a struct, which I could right-hand click and split the
struct pin. That's going to give me a lot more outputs, a lot more details.
So it's going to tell us where this line trace has hit. Again, left-hand side,
we have the input nodes. On the right-hand side, we have the output nodes.
That brings us to the end of this video. Thank you very much for sticking with us
and I will see you in the next.